[Musique]
bonjour tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité au parlement
et au sénat est avec moi pour présenter
cette émission
elton tran huy bonjour tam bonjour
brigitte un bonjour laurence rossignol
voulez vous êtes notre invité
aujourd'hui et on va voir votre parcours
politique
en quelques mots il vous a vu passer des
rangs de la lcr de l'espoir du grand
soir au parti socialiste en 1981
conquête par les urnes et gauche de
gouvernement vous avez d'ailleurs été
ministre des famille de l'enfance et des
droits des femmes sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande
votre signe distinctif le féminisme
chevillée au corps et les constitutifs
de votre engagement politique puisque
vous avez d'ailleurs fait partie des
pétroleuses du mlf le mouvement de
libération des femmes pendant le
confinement duo qu'ovide vous avez
beaucoup dénoncé la fragilisation de
l'accès à l'ivg et j'ai pendant cette
période
laurence rossignol autres victimes
possibles du coc vide la loi de
bioéthique et sa mesure phare la pma
pour toutes
gilles legendre le patron des députés de
la république en marche espère pouvoir
adopter le texte d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
ça vous inquiète vous n'avez parquet sur
un petit peu enterrés ce texte
puis quand un président de groupe dit
que il espère pouvoir adopter le texte
avant la fin du quinquennat on n'entend
qu'eux il craint de ne pas pouvoir
l'adopter ou le salut est peut-être
aussi indifférent de ne pas pouvoir
l'adopter je ne sais pas en tous les cas
une alerte dans son propos est en fait
on est là sur cette affaire de loi
bioéthique sur quelque chose qui dès le
départ a été mal engagée il n'était pas
utile de mettre la pma pour toutes dans
la loi bioéthique
ce n'est pas un problème de bioéthique
la progression la procréation
médicalement assistée est déjà une
technique dont dont on connaît beaucoup
de choses et qu'on a déjà pu évaluer sur
le plan éthique
après la décision de l'ouvrir aux
couples de femmes ou femme seule est une
décision politique et non pas une
décision de bioéthique donc le
gouvernement a enfoui dirais-je la pma
pour toutes dans la loi de bioéthique on
sait qu un process de loi de bioéthique
est très long parce que on a beaucoup de
sujets il ya deux inconvénient à ça le
premier c'est que la pma pour tout n'est
toujours pas votée le deuxième c'est
qu'elle ait beaucoup de sujets très
importants dans la rue bioéthique
cherche de recherche sur l'embryon toute
une série de choses très importantes qui
du coup n'ont pas n'ont pas franchi la
barre médiatique qui a été jusqu'au
grand public parce que les pma pour tout
à cacher tout le reste a phagocyté tout
le reste et on est là avec ni loi
bioéthique millavois pma pour tourner on
est dans une crise épidémique sans
précédent est ce que c'est vraiment
l'urgence de faire cette loi bioéthique
je peux pas dire que soit l'urgence de
faire un bts qui était apparemment une
urgence quand même c'était celle des
femmes qui demandaient que la pma pour
tout soit voté de façon à ce qu'elles
cessent de se rendre à l'étranger pour
faire une pma donc c'est un engagement
du président de la république dans sa
campagne de 2017 et je vois qu'il y
avait des urgences dans ses engagements
de campagne qui était pour lui et pour
cette majorité en marche plus important
que la pma pour tout donc on peut être
inquiet à cette étape et on aimerait
bien que le gouvernement nous donne un
calendrier mais franchement s'il n'y
arrive pas à faire voter la loi
bioéthique qui sortent la pma la loi
bioéthique qui fasse un projet doit avec
urgence comme ils le savent très bien le
faire pour des tas de sujets et convoque
la pma rapidement un arc deux articles
et c'est bon et on va revenir d'ailleurs
sur le fonctionnement du parlement voici
les titres de cette émission feu vert du
parlement à l'application stop coville
l'application controversée de traçage
numérique qui doit permettre de freiner
la propagation du virus
elle sera disponible à partir du 2 juin
ils portent diverses dispositions
urgentes le projet de loi fourre tout a
été passé par le sénat à la moulinette
et en sort expurgée de la moitié de ces
ordonnances des dons de congés ou des
rtt à convertir en chèques vacances
voilà la proposition de loi défendue par
le député et christophe blanche est
adoptée en commission elle sera débattue
mardi dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
et pour commencer cette émission le feu
vert du parlement à l'application stop
qu'ovide
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
débat sous tension à l'assemblée
nationale opposition plus feutrée au
sénat où la droite majoritaire a soutenu
le gouvernement stoppe qu'ovide fait
débat outils de sécurité sanitaire pour
les uns atteinte aux libertés pour les
autres résumé des discussions par marie
brémond devant les parlementaires de
l'assemblée ou du sénat
même discours de la part de l'exécutif
qui après avoir revu sa copie plusieurs
fois présentait son projet de loi de
l'application de traçage stop qu'ovide
le téléchargement de cette application
de cette installation et résulte d'une
démarche volontaire de l'utilisateur son
installation est libre et gratuite
toutes les fonctionnalités ne pourront
être activés que si l'utilisateur le
souhaite et la désinstallation est
possible à tout moment
un discours qui se veut rassurant la
garde des sceaux récusant tout pistage
où tout fichage des français
mais à l'assemblée nationale où le
gouvernement dispose pourtant d'une
majorité confortable
l'opposition a été vigoureuse les
échanges nourris et tendue à l'image de
jean luc mélenchon qui s'inquiète d'une
société sous surveillance généralisée
après avoir jugulé en danger le virus
que 8,19 on pourrait en juguler d'autre
part une connaissance mutuelle plus
approfondie chers collègues y avez vous
vu la tuberculose mon téléphone me le
dira etes-vous mauvais payeur au moment
où vous rentrerez dans le magasin le
téléphone durera cet homme est déjà dans
le rouge
ne lui donnez plus rien etc etc à droite
on profite de cette tribune pour
dénoncer la politique gouvernementale en
matière de santé ne faisons pas croire
aux français que cette application sera
l'alpha et l'oméga de la lutte contre le
coc vide
ce sont les soignants qui sauve les vies
ce sont les masques dont nous avons tant
manqué qui sauve les vies
ce sont les tests qui ont fait si
cruellement défaut par le confinement
qui sauve les vies
vous avez préféré agité un écran de
fumée avec cette application pour mieux
masquer vos propres fautes défaillance
est qu au monde de salles deux ambiances
est une illustration d'un désaccord au
sein de la famille des républicains
le patron dlr au sénat se rallient
derrière le projet du gouvernement au
nom de la lutte contre la pandémie
le traçage est essentiel parce que
lorsqu'une personne tombe malade il est
fondamental de pouvoir
retrouvez pour les alerter celles et
ceux qu'elle a pu croiser et
possiblement évidemment contaminés c'est
absolument essentiel un texte finalement
adopté par le sénat mais aussi par
l'assemblée l'application sera déployé
en début de semaine prochaine
laurence rossignol votre groupe au sénat
a unanimement voté contre
pourquoi et peut-être on vient tout
petit peu en arrière sur la loi urgence
2 dans laquelle le gouvernement nous a
proposé la mise en place d'un système de
recueil des données confiées à
l'assurance-maladie du tour du fichier
l'inconscient d'un fichier on a compris
comment ça se passe quand une personne
va chez le médecin le médecin
diagnostique une copine à ce moment là
le médecin envoie officier à l'assurance
maladie
les quotas là les corps de sept
personnes la personne est ensuite
contacté et elle informe la laine son
interlocuteur des personnes qu'elle a
rencontrées pendant la période
d'incubation ce après quoi les la
brigade de l'assurance maladie
contact les personnes qui ont été en
contact avec la personne malade au
moment où on a voté cette ce fichier là
on a eu déjà un gros débat sur la
question des libertés de la mise en
place d'un fichier de sa durée de vie
mais vous l'avez voter en quoi ça va
plus les non seulement je vais voter
mais j'ai fait partie de celles qui
défendent est et de celles et ceux qui
défendent est la mise en place de
fichiers parce qu'effectivement le
traçage et le contact font partie de la
de la prévention contre la propagation
du covan 19 mai je crois qu'on a ce
qu'il nous faut avec 7,7 ce système qu
est un système contrôlé qui est entre
les mains de l'assurance maladie qui
avec kate qui est contrôlé par des
médecins et qui est un système dassault
va lieux publics
là on nous propose une application qui
est une application facultative dans un
certain nombre de pays où elle a été
développée des poules elle n'a pas
produit d'effet les gens non parlons pas
à quoi télécharger donc une gouvernance
est un des instruments parmi d'autres
moi j'ai le sentiment était d'avantagé
sentiment que le gouvernement je ne
dérange pas s'il faut dire le
gouvernement dans cette affaire où le
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
voilà cedrico
qui en a fait une obsession est un sujet
très personnel car envie d'avoir une
technologie est de porter une nouvelle
technologie
philippe l'a rejoint quand même il a dit
c'est un outil extrêmement puissant
cette semaine il a enjoint tous les
français à télécharger l'application du
gouvernement je ne ferai pas par exemple
vous n'allez moi j'ai chargé cette
application sa superfétatoire par
rapport au système centralisé qu'on a
mis en place il ya moins de 15 jours
et puis par ailleurs à un moment donné
on peut se poser aussi l'action de
savoir jusqu'à quel point on veut tout
le temps être avec le bluetooth les
données et toutes nos données stockées
et je pense qu'on est tous d'accord pour
dire que le système qu'on a mis en place
est bien celui là est une une espèce de
marotte technologique d'un gouvernement
qui veut absolument montrer qu'il est
très performant sur le plan humain que
vous avez un téléphone portable que vous
utilisez google ou amazon qui ont
énormément de données sur vous sur votre
consommation sur votre façon de vivre
finalement est-ce que ça va tellement
plus loin est ce que c'est tellement
plus liberticide que sega femmes
mais la question c'est que c'est celle
de l'efficacité si on mène mais si on
admet l'idée que lors que dès lors
qu'une personne ait diagnostiqué
qu'ovide elle est prise en charge par le
système de recueil des données sous
l'autorité de l'assurance maladie
qu'est ce que ce système là va donner de
plus et qu'on va on va savoir qu'on a
été dans une rame de métro ou dans un
train avec quelqu'un qui à l'aube ou du
compartiment ensuite un même des clients
aux principes
meetic a été nommé ce ticket coville
ceci me paraît être une marotte
technologique beaucoup plus qu'une
décision sanitaire damien abad est
certainement d'accord avec vous il juge
que ce top cow vide c'est un écran de
fumée face aux défaillances de l'état
sur les tests de masque on l'a entendue
dans le reportage à l'instant est ce que
ça donne le ton des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires écoutez je ne
sais pas ce qui se passera à l'assemblée
nationale monsieur commission denquête
assemblée nationale dès lors qu'elle
vise l'exercice du pouvoir par le
gouvernement sont toujours un peu
particulière pour dire les choses en
soutenant la ferme de la commune enquête
benalla au sénat je sais que nous allons
travailler sérieusement notre but n'est
pas la mise en accusation des uns et des
autres notre but c'est de comprendre
comment l'état a pu être aussi peu près
paré dans un certain nombre de domaines
en particulier les masques puis les
tests
comment l'état a pu nous raconter dans
un premier temps que les masques ne
servait à rien puis après qui servait
que à ce qu'avait que vit depuis en fin
de compte qui servait peut-être à tout
le monde et puis quand même endroit
peut-être en avoir comme voilà donc tous
les responsables it et partager avec les
exécutifs précédent est ce que vous
allez remonter pour vous est il
nécessaire par exemple auditionné
marisol touraine exprimer je pense que
tous ceux qui ont été en charge de
l'hôpital public est en charge des
politiques publiques de santé au cours
des dix dernières années auront des
choses à dire devant la commission
denquête ça me paraît normal on voyait
on voit bien que mal de l'auditionner
les masques les masques sont un sujet
mais il n'ya pas que les masques il ya
le nombre de lits de réanimation dans
l'hôpital public le ratio entre le
nombre d'habitants le nombre de lits
l'étal de piano de lumière à faire agnès
buzyn vous devez l'entendre rapidement
dans cette commission denquête coûte la
vie pendant qu'elle va se mettre en
place au mois de juin
on va peut-être la laisser faire sa
campagne municipale à paris et je pense
que après les municipales
il n'y a pas eu organismes nocifs and
mail allen dit elle même qu'elle avait
hâte d'être auditionné pour faire la
lumière sur son sur son rôle c'est
formidable et là de tout d'être
auditionné d'être en campagne
bref vous l'entendrez donc après le 28
juin poursuit cette émission avec le
projet portant sur diverses mesures
urgentes pour faire face aux
conséquences de l'épidémie kovy de 19
[Musique]
ce texte qui porte diverses dispositions
urgentes est un assemblage hétéroclite
un de mesures pour faire face à
l'épidémie comme aubrac cite par exemple
un projet de loi très critiqué par les
sénateurs car il abuse selon un des
ordonnances audrey vieux états les
sénateurs ont trouvé un surnom à ce
texte certains ont même dit il
s'agissait d'un projet gloubiboulga
difficile selon eux de déceler un fil
conducteur ton ils brassent de sujets
pêle-mêle l'allongement du délai dit vg
pendant les as du rj ans l'indemnisation
des victimes d'essais nucléaires ou les
règles du chômage partiel
c'est ce périmètre ministériel sont
concernés le texte du gouvernement
prévoyait aussi 42 monde pour légiférer
par ordonnance
sur ces sujets très différents c'est une
procédure exceptionnelle qui permet de
prendre une mesure sans débat
parlementaire
en pleine crise 57 ordonnance ont été
acceptés 40 de plus ce serait beaucoup
trop pour les deux chambres
nous ne devons pas faire perdurer cette
pratique initial justifiée par la
situation mais qui aujourd'hui ne l'est
plus des semaines après le début de la
crise petit à petit un phénomène
d'accoutumance à la marginalisation du
parlement s'installe or comme le thon le
parlement est malmené fait la démocratie
qui fabien après lecture des deux
chambres le texte n'autorise plus qu'une
petite dizaine d'ordonnancé pour le
parlement la crise ne permet pas tout en
matière de justice notamment le sénat
l'a rappelé hier concernant un
amendement du gouvernement
il visait à étendre les cours
criminelles un dispositif testé depuis
moins d'un an avec des cours d'assises
sans jurés populaires nous avons besoin
de ce dispositif pour faire face dans
certains départements aux difficultés
qu'ont vont rencontrer les cours
d'assises dans le contexte de la reprise
d'activité lié aux vies 19 réponse des
sénateurs vaut profiter de la situation
pour opérer un bouleversement de notre
système judiciaire
quel que soit notre désir d'être utile à
la résolution des problèmes
d'encombrement de la justice ne pouvons
pas accepter cette évolution
l'amendement a été rejeté le sénat
demande un vrai débat à une fois
l'expérimentation terminée
rappelé en filigrane l'important
du temps long laurence rossignol est ce
que ce projet de loi était nécessaire
pour différer différentes dispositions
techniques pendant l'état d'urgence
probablement quelques unes étaient
nécessaires je pense par exemple à la
prolongation de l'expérimentation sur
les maisons de naissance qui allait
s'éteindre fin novembre et on avait
besoin de légiférer
le gouvernement a amendé la loi
précédente et a prolongé d'un an ça
c'était nécessaire mais plus plus
largement qu'est-ce-qui observons ce qui
se passe depuis le début d'état
d'urgence le gouvernement vient au
parlement que pour des mesures d'urgence
et à chaque fois pour demander au
parlement de se dessaisir de ses
compétences et pour donner au
gouvernement la possibilité le droit de
légiférer à la fin à la place du
parlement
mais ça c'est vu qu'il avait décidé dans
l'état d'urgence sanitaire de donner
plus de pouvoir à chaque fois le
gouvernement vient demander de nouvelles
habitations
on peut considérer que certaines étaient
utiles comme par exemple pour mettre en
place des dispositions sur les limites à
la liberté d'aller et venir pour un
certain nombre de mesures de départ mais
après en quoi est il utile aujourd'hui
de réorganiser aussi bien la justice les
finances les rapports avec paris et 20
articles 3 ans et du pouvoir dans c'est
alors la butte pouvoir supposerait que
ce ne soit pas légal mais c'est un
exercice maximum de ce que la loi permet
mais surtout l ennemi n'est possible que
si le parlement est d'accord pour se
dessaisir de son pouvoir de légiférer
or le sénat qui quand même depuis 2010
est en charge quasiment seule la
question de la vie parlementaire
la question démocratique la question du
respect du parlement le sénat en charge
ce un seul puisque l'assemblée nationale
est composée d'une majorité qui était
jusqu'à présent extrêmement vaste
extrêmement docile à l'égard du
gouvernement et qui n'était pas
préoccupé parce que peut-être manque
d'expérience manque de compréhension de
la nature de nos institutions et du rôle
du parlement dans la démocratie
l'assemblée nationale se dessaisit très
facilement en fait la majorité en marche
donne très facilement gouvernement de
ses compétences
donc c'est le sénat qui est chargé de
veiller à l'équilibré des pouvoirs et
c'est le sénat qu'il fait une fois de
plus dans ce texte
avec à la fois la majorité de droite
mais
aussi la gauche au sénat et à
l'assemblée en disant stop rêve
maintenant si vous voulez légiférer vous
venez avec vos textes
il ya une réduction du nombre des
ordonnances à l'assemblée et au sénat
l'assemblée a aussi agi sur ce sujet oui
mais en face le sénat a quand même
considérablement restreint les ans le
nombre de la publication parce que
nombreux d'habilitation parce que des
sujets le gouvernement on peut on peut
siéger
on vit comme si on ne pouvait pas siéger
mais on peut siéger sur d'autres textes
que les lois d'urgence ou une éponge loi
de finances rectificative a dit que ça
laisse des marques que ça marginalise le
parlement cette période je crains que de
la part d'un gouvernement que je juge
déjà que je qualifie déjà comme étant un
gouvernement peu enclin à faire vivre le
parlement peu enclin à défendre et
respecter l'équilibré des pouvoirs et
très enclin à gouverner seul sans le
parlement je crains que la période était
un élan un effet d'aubaine on nous a
parlé l'autre jour d'effets d'aubaine
à propos du thym d'un amendement sur les
frais bancaires ou le gouvernement
addiction limiter les frais bancaires
savait faire un effet d'aubaine pour les
peler les familles fragiles on a l'âge
elle veut que le parlement pouvaient
légiférer vite et bien vous savez
habilité le gouvernement à prendre des
ordonnances ce n'est pas lié sapphire
est bien gérée vite et on a
effectivement légiférer aussi vite
oui et non parce qu'on a quand même
travaillé sur chacun et chacune des
dispositions qui nous étaient soumises
mais nous aspirons nous parlement a
retrouvé nos compétences et notre
travail habituel
un mot sur le rejet de justesse d'un
amendement que vous avez porté plusieurs
fois depuis le début du confinement pour
l'allongement temporaire du délai d' ivg
de douze à quatorze semaines une fois de
plus cela n'est pas passé au sénat cette
semaine
oui parce qu'on sait que le confinement
l'état d'urgence la désorganisation des
hôpitaux et la concentration du travail
sur les cadres elle sur la réanimation a
eu un effet délétère sur l'accès aux ivg
et puis j'ajoute quand même con on a
tous constaté et la presse a été très
très très bon relais dans cette affaire
que les violences conjugales avait
beaucoup augmenté pendant la période de
confinement et je rappelle toujours que
dans violences conjugales inya violent
et que l'augmentation dès violences
conjugales peut malheureusement ou
si conduire à une augmentation des
grossesses non désirées et les médecins
et nous ont alertés très vite en nous
disant on a un problème avec les délais
dit vg qui sont trop courts par rapport
d'abord aux femmes qui étaient déjà hors
délai au moment du confinement des 13
mars et qui devait partir à l'étranger
qui n'ont pas par pu partir à l'étranger
les jeunes femmes c'est pas si simple de
quitter la maison avec son autorisation
en disant ça a été rejetée hier
pourquoi la droite conservatrice
finalement je vais venir
c'est pas si simple donc le sujet était
réel il ya les médecins le disent et le
planning familial le dit aussi
et le gouvernement c'est été obstinément
du thé et hostiles à cet allongement des
délais à chaque fois qu'on en a parlé à
javron les alerter ils ont dit non on
reste dans les délais qu'elle est elle
qui sont pour les délais légaux dvg et
ils ont trouvé hier au sénat avec l'aide
la plus conservatrice du sénat un
excellent partenaire pour rejeter cet
amendement qui pourtant a eu beaucoup
plus de voix qu'il n'en avait eu des
fois précédentes et donc il nous en
faudrait y revenir une quatrième fois
peut-être pour avoir la majorité
mais je désespère de convaincre ce
gouvernement qui je le rappelle avait
raconté qu'ils aient des femmes la
grande cause du quinquennat mais qui
quand il est face à un vrai sujet sur la
détresse des femmes est incapable de
prendre la décision qu'il faut prendre
et préfère s'allier avec les
conservateurs elle est laurence
rossignol dernier thème de cette
émission les dons de congé pour les
soignants
[Musique]
une initiative parlementaire pour aider
les soignants en première ligne dans la
crise du coronavirus le député la
république en marche christophe blanchet
propose de pouvoir donner des congés ou
des rtt à convertir en chèques vacances
au personnel de l'hôpital pour améliorer
leurs vacances et bien la proposition de
loi adoptée en commission sera débattu
mardi prochain dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale
l amont à gaza après les
applaudissements tous les soirs à 20h
comment prolonger cette reconnaissance
de la nation aux personnels soignants
pourquoi ne pas permettre aux français
de leur donner des rtt ou des jours de
repos transformer en chèques vacances
j'ai la solution retenue qui consiste à
convertir les jours de repos donnait en
chèques vacances permet d'apporter un
soutien visible aux soignants qui
pourront davantage profiter sur leurs
temps libres de loisirs supplémentaires
musée par l'attraction voyages
restaurants théâtres un loisir
supplémentaires dans une des 200 milles
structure en france dédié au tourisme et
à la culture qui accepte les chèques
vacances
pour la députée en soumises caroline
fiat par ailleurs aide soignante
c'est à l'état de se montrer plus
généreux on va demander aux employés
libre-service ans va demander au facteur
ans va demander aux éboueurs
on va demander aux mamans et qui te
faisait du télétravail de de faire don
aussi c'est à l'état de mettre en place
ces aides
côté républicain on s'agace surtout de
s'être fait voler l'idée fin mars le
député maximino proposait déjà
d'autoriser le don de congés bref je
veux parler ici de la méthode
une méthode qui constitue une faute
déontologique majeure consistant à
reprendre une proposition de
l'opposition ligne aurait volontairement
et sans attribuer les mérites la
majorité se défend d'avoir plagié
maximino voulait donner des rtt là il
s'agit de les transformer en chèques
vacances
la proposition de loi a été adopté en
commission elle sera débattu dans
l'hémicycle mardi prochain laurence
rossignol est ce que vous êtes favorable
à cette initiative
écoutez je ne sais pas s'il va venir au
sénat c'est une proposition voix de
l'assemblée
et moi je suis favorable à tout ce qui
permet aux français de manifester leur
générosité
bien entendu mais je suis comme un peu
gêné par cette proposition de loi
d'abord il ya quand même l'idée que les
rtt en or est trop et je ne peux pas
empêcher de penser que les mêmes qui
porte cette proposition de loi
aujourd'hui les nerfs ou une partie de
sedan marche sont ceux qui ne manque
jamais de nous rappeler que les 35
heures sont un boulet dans l'économie
française et que les français ont trop
de vacances trop de congés trop de rtt
et donc là l'idée c'est que mon oreille
trop de rtt donc on les donnerais
première remarque donc j'ai un peu
perplexe sur sur le fond qui existe déjà
pour des salariés d'une même entreprise
le mécanisme existe mais dans un cas
très particulier c'est des salariés
d'une entreprise quand y'a un d'entre
eux qu'à un enfant très malade et qui
doit s'absenter pour accompagner un
enfant malade
par ailleurs je pense que la générosité
elle doit être incarné humainement ce
n'est pas simplement faire un chèque
et là c'est faire un chèque vacances et
moi je pense qu'il faut aussi favoriser
la générosité la solidarité qui se
manifeste d'être humain à être humain
donc je trouve que cette proposition de
loi est probablement belle proposition
d'affichage je crois que les soignants
ont besoin d'argent ils en auront avec
ces chèques vacances probablement mais
quand même
les teams qui a des rtt aujourd'hui les
salariés des classes moyennes ils payent
des impôts
souvent ils trouvent même qu'ils en
paient beaucoup des impôts nos impôts
servent à financer notre système de
santé payé correctement les soignants et
leur donner leurs rtt et leurs congés
bien mérités à la fin de tout ça bref
enfin en conclusion je n'applaudis pas
dès demain parce qu'en plus je pense
qu'à la fin du confinement
tout ceux qui sont restés à la maison ou
qui ont été travaillés auront besoin de
se reposer ses qualités prendre et c'est
toujours l'idée derrière qu'on a trop de
rtt c'est pas vrai en tout cas et c'est
sûrement pas vrai pour les femmes qui
ont été doublement ou triplement mise à
contribution pendant la période qui
vient de s'écouler comme elles le sont
d'ailleurs toute l'année alors avant de
se quitter
laurence rossignol nous voulions rendre
un hommage à claude goasguen député les
républicains de paris est décédé ce
jeudi
un arrêt cardiaque après avoir contracté
le kovy de 19
il avait 75 ans ou chirac un convaincu
c'était une figure de la droite et du
parlement députés pendant plus de 20 ans
claude goasguen à l'assemblée c'était un
polémiste invétéré au verbe haut et au
fort tempérament libéral assumé il
s'était investi avec conviction dans la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme
voilà pour cette émission merci laurence
rossignol merci beaucoup leur entre
scaër d'avoir participé à cette émission
pas de petit mot sur claude goasguen
non mais moi j'ai jamais été élu de
paris donc j'ai pas ces génies député
claude goasguen
mais ce que je trouve qu'on vit une
période où tous les jours beaucoup
d'entre nous pleurs quelqu'un voilà hier
beaucoup en priorité au gaz guen on a
tous pleuré enfin moi ce qui me concerne
guy bedos
on a perdu nos henri weber l'ancien
sénateur député européen jean loup
dabadie et se trouve que depuis deux
mois
ce qu vide plus âge on a beaucoup
beaucoup de tristesse qui nous entoure
et le bilan humain et affectif de cette
période ce sera douloureux pour beaucoup
il entraîne ou le remercie beaucoup et
avec laurence rossignol on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro
mais par les moyens tôt
[Musique]